Hey, remember how Trump tweeted
that Obama wiretapped
Trump Tower during the election?
Well, according
to FBI Director James Comey,
there's no evidence for that!
In other obvious Internet news,
you totally cannot add
three inches to your (bleep),
and even if you could, there are
zero horny MILFs in your area.
(laughter)
-All right?
-(cheering, applause)
FBI director and national
spoilsport, James Comey,
testified to congress today
about Trump's claim, saying...
I have no information
that supports those tweets.
Yes, we're at the point
where the director
of a federal
law enforcement agency
has to take time out of his work
to talk about tweets.
-(laughter)
-Do you... I don't re...
I don't know if I remember
J. Edgar Hoover
having to deal with Grindr.
All right, bad example.
That is a bad example!
-(applause)
-It is a bad example.
-Now, comedi... Yes?
-I actually do remember him...
You do remember him.
Okay, great, you actually do...
It was a long night.
(Hardwick laughing)
I'm obviously gay.
What are we talking about?
-No! -♪ Thank you...
-(cheering)
-No!
-I know.
What's something else
you could tweet
to prompt that response from
FBI Director James Comey? Dom.
Women marry me
for my giant hands
and my tolerance of them coming
from any country on the planet.
(laughter)
I have no information
that supports those tweets.
-(laughter)
-Yes. Gina.
I have
the most diverse cabinet ever.
We have every shade,
from pasty to bloated corpse.
(laughter)
I have no information
that supports those tweets.
-(laughter)
-All right, points. Matteo.
Kellyanne Conway
is not a waterfall with eyes.
(laughter)
I have no information
that supports those tweets.
(laughter, applause)